keine trendwende in sicht der anstieg
der korona neuinfektionen geht weiter
außerdem gilt eine neue reisewarnung
große sorge um alex zehner wallen die
russische ärzte kämpfen um das leben des
kreml kritikers nach angaben seiner
sprecherin wurde er vergiftet keiner
kann sie stoppen bayern münchen steht im
finale der fußball champions league
die nachrichten nicht dass leute mit
christian sievers land hinein
ich begrüße sie sehr herzlich zum
nachrichtenüberblick um 19 uhr sport
nachher in der sendung mit christian
otten aber es zum siegeszug der bayern
genannt
es gibt viele fragen und viele sorgen zu
den crooner zahlen in deutschland heute
wieder mehr neuinfektionen so viele wie
zuletzt im april mit der alarm situation
im frühjahr ist die lage aber derzeit
nicht wirklich zu vergleichen vor allem
was die zahl der schweren fälle und die
belastung der krankenhäuser angeht
das robert koch institut registrierte
1707 neue fälle innerhalb eines tages im
schnitt der vergangenen woche haben sich
täglich 1260 menschen neu angesteckt
gestern waren es noch 1200 30 ein grund
für den anstieg
einige bringen das virus aus dem urlaub
mit jetzt warnt das auswärtige amt vor
reisen in teile kroatiens betroffen sind
die küstenregionen sibenik knien und
split dalmatien mit den inseln brac und
war aber nicht nur reiserückkehrer auch
größere feiern im freundes und
familienkreis lassen offenbar die
infektionszahlen ansteigen die
hintergründe jetzt von anselm stern
verdammt viel arbeit wartet hier im
gesundheitsamt groß gerau in dem
hessischen landkreis gab es eine große
hochzeitsfeier verteilt über zwei tage
mit 300 gästen eine frau hatte corona
sie steckte mehrere menschen an
die behörden müssten jetzt enorm viele
kontaktpersonen ermitteln
das ist eine riesenherausforderung für
das gesundheitsamt im moment alles was
die nachverfolgung anbetrifft ist das
gesamte gesundheitsamt im moment an den
grenzen seiner belastung corona probleme
wegen einer veranstaltung das virus ist
da im ganzen land aber die gute
nachricht ganz viele infizierte müssen
nicht ins krankenhaus
tödliche verläufe in deutschland aktuell
sehr selten im moment haben wir die
situation dass besonders junge menschen
betroffen sind 20 bis 25 jahre und da
eben besonders die männer hängt
sicherlich auch mit der reisetätigkeit
und dem was man im urlaub so macht
hti urlaub ist das stichwort zusammen
und bei jungen personen das wissen wir
ja verläuft diese erkrankung in der
regel oder wenn man sich das statistisch
anschaut eben milder
das virus unsichtbar da wächst schnell
die sorglosigkeit der heim- oder im
urlaub im ausland
die allermeisten infizierten rückkehrer
kamen in den vergangenen wochen aus dem
kosovo und der türkei aber auch aus
kroatien bulgarien oder bosnien und
herzegowina
es ist natürlich häufig so dass personen
dorthin reisen um ihre familien zu
besuchen das ist natürlich eine eine
naheliegende erklärung das zeigt sich
auch so ein bisschen an der struck
altersstruktur der personen die aus
diesen ländern kommen das sind auch
relativ häufig kinder dabei besucher
urlaub erholung unbeschwert ist das
schwer möglich in diesen krisen sommer
die krone reisewarnung für luxemburg hat
die bundesregierung heute aufgehoben
in der zdf- heute haben wir
zusammengestellt welche gegenden in
europa aktuell als risikogebiete gelten
und damit in der sendung in die usa und
zu einem historischen moment auf dem
parteitag der demokraten mit kamera
harris schicken sie erstmals eine
schwarze frau als vize kandidatin ins
rennen um die präsidentschaft für
aufsehen sorgte auch er barack obama
wohl noch nie hat ein ex präsident so
deutlich mit seinem nachfolger
abgerechnet obamas fazit trump sei eine
gefahr für die demokratie
er behandle die präsidentschaft wie eine
reality show und trumps versagen habe
schwerwiegende folgen heike slansky
nichts ist normal in diesen zeiten ein
parteitag virtuell perfekt durch
orchestriert ohne publikum
es ist ihr abend sie soll die bühne
füllen die erste schwarze
präsidentschaftskandidatin jetzt
offiziell donald runs führungsversagen
hat lieben und existenzen gekostet lasst
uns mit überzeugung kämpfen lasst uns
mit hoffnung kämpfen lasst uns mit
vertrauen in uns kennt
sweet people wir das volk so stellen
sich die demokraten da bunt vielfältig
patriotisch sie stehen für ein anderes
amerika für gleichheit mehr frauenrechte
bessere waffenkontrollen mehr
klimaschutz und humanere
einwanderungsregeln schutz vor
abschiebungen meine mutter ist eine gute
keine kriminelle auch das ist nicht
normal als frontalangriff eines
ehemaligen präsidenten zugeschaltet aus
philadelphia dem geburtsort der
us-verfassung symbolträchtig gewählt es
folgt eine düstere warnung 170000
amerikaner sind tot millionen jobs sind
weg während sich die ganz oben mehr
nehmen als je zuvor
unsere schlimmsten instinkte sind
entfesselt der gute ruf der usa hat
weltweit schaden genommen und unsere
demokratischen institutionen sind
bedroht wie nie zuvor
eine schonungslose abrechnung
außergewöhnlich scharf trank eine gefahr
für die älteste demokratie auch das
nicht normal
gratulation auf abstand die
hoffnungsträger mit einem gegenentwurf
der appell geht wählen
steve barron der frühere chef stratege
von donald trump ist wegen betrugs
festgenommen worden
er und drei weitere beschuldigte sollen
spendengelder unterschlagen haben die
rede ist von hunderttausenden dollar
eigentlich hätte das geld in den bau
einer mauer zwischen mexiko und den usa
fließen sollen
das projekt war eines der zentralen
wahlversprechen von donald trump eine
nachricht heute die besonders aufhorchen
lässt kommt aus russland dort kämpfen
die ärzte um das leben des bekannten
kreml kritikers alexej nawalny nach
angaben seiner sprecherin wurde
navalny vergiftet navalny war in der
vergangenheit bereits mehrfach
attackiert worden und wurde auch
mehrfach festgenommen
die galionsfigur der zersplitterten
russischen opposition hat sich dem kampf
gegen schmiergeld kultur und
vetternwirtschaft verschrieben
er hat sich viele feinde gemacht aus
moskau christiaanse alexej nawalny
schreit auf dem flug von toms nach
moskau klagt der regierungskritiker über
heftiges unwohlsein ein passagier filmt
das geschehen mit dem handy der flieger
müssen der stadt omsk notlanden navalny
wird ins krankenhaus gebracht dort liegt
er jetzt im koma sein zustand sei ernst
aber stabil sagen die ärzte
es gibt eine spezialabteilung in unserem
krankenhaus um solche patienten zu
behandeln die ärzte tun alles mögliche
um sein leben zu retten
navalny sprecherin ist sich sicher er
wurde vergiftet
am flughafen toms hatte er noch einen
tee getrunken das soll der moment sein
den ein passagier fotografierte das gift
könnte indem t gewesen sein so die
vermutung
alexej nawalny ist der bekannte kopf der
unterdrückten opposition in russland
regelmäßig kritisiert er die regierung
und präsident putin organisiert proteste
und deckt korruptionsskandale in der
russischen elite auf der 44 jährige hat
sich im laufe der jahre viele feinde in
russland gemacht immer wieder wurde er
festgenommen und zu haftstrafen
verurteilt
auch mehrere angriffe wurden bereits auf
ihn verübt 2017 eine farbattacke bei der
er am auge verletzt wurde
aus dem kreml hieß es dass es sich um
eine vergiftung handelte könne man noch
nicht bestätigen
man wünsche navalny die jedem bürger der
russischen föderation eine schnelle
genesung
da bleiben viele fragen geben wir live
nach moskau zu christian selben
christian guten abend was ist das für
ein klima im land dass man überhaupt
dazu kommt navalny könnte vergiftet
worden sein
naja das klima ist so dass viele hier
leider gar nicht mehr überrascht sind
wenn so eine tat passiert denn wer sich
mit den mächtigen anlegt lebt gefährlich
es gab in der vergangenheit ja schon
ähnlich gelagerte vergiftungsfälle es
wird jetzt natürlich wild spekuliert was
die motive seien könnten für eine solche
tat die sind in erster linie im
politischen bereich zu suchen könnten
aber auch im wirtschaftlichen bereich
liegen dennoch war es mit seinen
korruptions ermittlungen ja auch vielen
mächtigen
wirklich auf die füße getreten eine
andere variante die heute auch noch
diskutiert wurde ist dass die tat auch
ein ablenkungsmanöver sein könnte um von
den protesten in belarus abzulenken
man weiss wirklich noch nichts es gibt
noch nichts zu den hintergründen
das sind alles nur spekulationen aber
ich finde diese bandbreite zeigt
eigentlich schon was menschen glauben
was hier in diesem land möglich sein
kann wenn es denn eine vergiftung war
herzlichen dank christian semler moskau
und gerade kommen heil meldungen nach
denen bundeskanzlerin angela merkel die
medizinische behandlung von navalny in
deutschland angeboten hat wir merken
also schon das schicksal von navalny das
war heute auch thema beim treffen von
kanzlerin merkel mit frankreichs
präsident emanuel makro die beiden
treffen sich jetzt im moment erstmals
auf dem sommersitz des französischen
staatschefs am mittelmeer
trotz malerischer kulisse zu besprechen
gibt es viel da sind die europäischen
maßnahmen gegen die korona krise die
lage in belarus und der türkisch
griechische konflikte mittelmeer
das ziel wieder mehr gemeinsam statt
einsam live rüber zur thomas walde vor
der wirklich offenbar sehr angenehmen
sommerresidenz des französischen
präsidenten thomas guten abend wie
wollen denn die beiden jetzt
sicherstellen dass europa gerade bei
corona künftig wirklich nur noch
gemeinsam handelt sie haben da in zwei
bereichen gemeinsamkeiten zumindest
umrissen bei ihrem gemeinsamen auftritt
eine betrifft den wirt wiederaufbauplan
europas der die wirtschaftlichen folgen
des corona virus der krise bekämpfen
soll
da hat im manual macau angekündigt für
die kommenden wochen es würde würden
vorgestellt starke deutsch-französische
investitionsprojekte angela merkel hat
die bei geschlichtet und beide mahnten
auch ihre europäischen partner an die
gelder dieses europäischen wiederaufbau
plans in zukunftsindustrien zu
investieren es gehe jetzt darum diesen
plan umzusetzen
und beide wollen in den kommenden wochen
deutsche mit konkreten projekten so
kündigten sie es an vorangehen der
zweite bereich betrifft die steigenden
infektionszahlen von denen wir ja auch
gerade eben gehört haben beide meinten
man dürfe auf europäischer ebene die
fehler die man zu anfang dieser krise
gemacht hat auf gar keinen fall
wiederholen
doch viele staaten für sich allein
unterwegs waren sie mahnten eine
strengere bessere europäische
koordinierung hier in diesen fällen an
sie sagten grenzschließungen müssten
unbedingt vermieden werden
entscheidungen sollten gestützt werden
auf wissenschaftliche fakten
beispielsweise auf bestimmte grenzwerte
bei neuinfektionen wenn man dort
objektive maßstäbe habe dann sei das
auch für bürgerinnen und bürger
einleuchtend und makro meinte auch in
einem bereich in der zukunft wolle man
besser koordinieren besser gemeinsam
unterwegs sein
bei der entwicklung und dann auch
verteilung von impfstoffen also sie
haben zumindest umrissen wohin die reise
gehen soll ein zentraler begriff dabei
war europäische souveränität angesichts
von spannung amerikanern und chinesen
sei der wie immer wichtiger
und dieser begriff fiel hier ein halbes
dutzend bis zu einem dutzend mal da soll
die reise hingehen thomas vielen dank
und damit zurück nach deutschland zwei
tage nach dem schockierenden anschlag in
berlin suchen die ermittler weiter nach
dem motiv des täters bei den mutmaßlich
islamistischen täter geht die
staatsanwaltschaft von einem zitat
bizarren religiösen wahn aus das ergab
ein psychiatrisches gutachten eine
schuldunfähigkeit sei deswegen nicht
ausgeschlossen
der 30 jährige iraker hatte mit seinem
auto offenbar absichtlich mehrere
unfälle verursacht sechs menschen wurden
zum teil schwer verletzt ein mann liegt
weiter auf der intensivstation
und jetzt zu einem polizeieinsatz über
den viele in diesem land seit fast einer
woche diskutieren passiert in der
düsseldorfer altstadt vergangenen
samstag ein jugendlicher greift einen
polizisten an der drückt ihn zu boden
macht ihn so kampfunfähig
ein fall von unzulässiger polizeigewalt
eher nicht meint der zuständige
innenminister er sagt heute im landtag
man müsse den ganzen vorgang sehen torge
bode
es ist dieses video das die debatte über
polizeigewalt wieder neu angestoßen
hatte ein 15-jähriger liegt auf dem
boden ein polizeibeamter fixiert ihn
drückt dazu sein knie auf dessen kopf
war diese maßnahme verhältnismäßig damit
befasste sich heute der innenausschuss
im düsseldorfer landtag
ich war erschrocken über die bilder
heutige faktenlage ist das die erste
eindruck nicht der richtige ist aber es
ist nur ein erster eindruck ein zweiter
eindruck und wir haben es nicht
abschließend bewertet der 15 jährige war
der polizei bekannt auch wegen früherer
gewalttaten am wochenende solle einen
laufenden einsatz gestört und die
beamten dann angegriffen haben
die reagieren wie gesehen die zuständige
aus bildungsbehörde für polizeibeamte in
nrw hatte das video analysiert und kommt
zu dem schluss die angewandte eingriffs
technik entspricht den in aus und
fortbildung vermittelten techniken so
eine anwendung unmittelbaren zwanges ist
immer ein dynamischer prozess in einer
position kommt man sagen r rutscht ab
auf den hals geht aber sofort wieder auf
den kopf zurück und das ist das
entscheidende dass er das codiert ein
freispruch es das allerdings nicht gegen
den beamten wird weiter wegen
körperverletzung im amt ermittelt ob es
zur anklage kommt wird die
staatsanwaltschaft in düsseldorf
entscheiden ganz anderes thema jetzt
gerade in corona zeiten boomt essen to
go und das bedeutet in der regel auch
jede menge verpackungsmüll und der wird
vor allem dann zum problem wenn er auf
der straße oder im grünen landet
einwegprodukte machen zusammen mit
zigarettenkippen mehr als 40 prozent des
straßen mülls aus und das wegzuräumen
kostet die kommunen jährlich rund 700
millionen euro
die umweltministerinnen will deshalb
dass sich die wirtschaft beteiligt
patricia wiedemeier wegen corona wurde
in diesem jahr mehr draußen gefeiert
damit auch mehr müll hinterlassen 140
liter straßen müll produziert jeder
einwohner pro jahr eine ganze badewanne
voll so das ergebnis einer studie die
heute in berlin vorgestellt wurde
die entsorgung sie kostet millionen
künftig sollen auch die hersteller dafür
aufkommen
ich möchte die kosten anders parteien
ich möchte den bürgerinnen und bürger
entlasten und die einweg klaffte
hersteller stärker zogen kasse bieten
bitten das ist eine frage der
gerechtigkeit
es geht vor allem um einwegbecher tüten
zigarettenstummel allein die entsorgung
von kiffen kostet 225 millionen euro pro
jahr und von to go becher 120 millionen
die hersteller sollen sich nicht nur an
den kosten für die entsorgung beteiligen
sondern auch auf plastik am besten schon
bei der herstellung verzichten fordert
der verband kommunaler unternehmen und
großteil dieser abfälle mit mehr als 40
prozent kunststoff und verpackungen
vieles davon wäre längst schon
vermeidbar wenn die hersteller mehr auf
eine art von sparsamen produktdesign
oder erst recht auf mehrweg setzen
würden die opposition fordert zuerst
einmal schärfere kontrollen und strafen
für die illegale müllentsorgung man kann
also schon bußgelder erheben es wird nur
flächendeckend nicht geahndet die leute
schmeißen ihre zigarettenkippen
schmeißen ihre kaffeebecher weg und es
interessiert keinen und da hätte viel
früher schon gehandelt werden müssen
eine gute nachricht gibt es aber jetzt
schon ab dem nächsten sommer sind in der
gesamten eu plastikgeschirr strohhalme
und styropor welcher verboten
jetzt freue ich mich auf den sport sich
auch genauer champions league die bayern
fast am ziel das zweite triple der
vereinsgeschichte rückt immer näher
denn der fc bayern münchen steht zum
sechsten mal im endspiel der
königsklasse ohne glanz vorstellung aber
mit drei treffern gegen olympique lyon
wurde in lissabon der finaleinzug
gesichert
bayern vor der krönung ein deutlicher
sieg dennoch ein hartes stück arbeit
das mussten verhindern dass es kein
einfaches spiel wird aber wir sind sehr
sehr glücklich dass ich unser ziel
erreicht haben vor allem in der
anfangsphase stellte lyon die
unsortierten bayern vor probleme dpa in
der vierten minute wenig später kombi an
den pfosten
da haben wir das ganze mit glück
überstanden und letztendlich war die
einzelleistung von von session april für
uns einfach auch ein bisschen eine
beruhigung im spiel übrigens
führungstreffer in der 18 minute
herrlich nahezu unhaltbar für keeper
lopez von spielern für sie zu mir gesagt
wenn ich nicht hiess
kann es auch keine torchance gegeben und
zum glück habe ich hart geschossenen
erster rein bayerns matchwinner der auch
zum 2 0 vollendete kurz vor schluss
erzielte robert lewandowski
seinen 15 treffer in dieser champions
league saison drei zu null
der traum vom triple lebt weiter absolut
und das finale der champions league
können sie am sonntagabend live hier bei
uns im zdf sehen unsere übertragungen
aus lissabon wird um 20.15 beginnen eins
ist klar mit dem französischen meister
paris arena unter coach thomas tuchel
bekommen es die bayern mit einer
mannschaft der extraklasse zu tun
sie sind heiß auf ihren ersten
champions-league-titel paris super star
ensemble das sich unter trainer thomas
tuchel als echte einheit präsentiert vor
allem auf solch raffinierte aktionen wie
von nena und die maria hier im
halbfinale gegen leipzig müssen sich die
bayern jetzt einstellen
die sind immer darauf aus das nächste
tor zu erzielen und wenn wir da den ball
verlieren gegen paris dann geht die post
ab
solche abwehr schwächen die sich die
bayern im halbfinale immer wieder
leisteten während für nena und co in
ihrem ersten champions league finale
wohl ein gefundenes fressen
thomas tuchel der mit seiner mannschaft
hier direkt am ufer des tejo abgestiegen
ist wird all die chancen die die bayern
zugelassen haben mit einiger vor freude
gesehen haben mp die maria diemer werden
daraus weit mehr machen als lyon und das
wissen die bayern das wird ein top
fußball gipfel am sonntagabend hier bei
uns ja top fernsehen im zdf vielen dank
an dich hochsommer in deutschland haben
wir ja und doch irgendwie gleichzeitig
vorweihnachtszeit diese becker im
erzgebirge arbeit nämlich jetzt schon
auf hochtouren stollen backen für das
anstehende weihnachtsgeschäft temperatur
in der backstube übrigens deutlich mehr
als 40 grad
trotzdem gilt weihnachten ist auch
dieses jahr am 24
dezember katja roll over sagt jetzt
gleich die wohl heißeste nacht des
jahres voraus wettermäßig zumindest und
die kollegin bettina schausten freut
sich auf sie im heute journal um 21.45
für heute danke gerne bis morgen in
allen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren das
wird vielleicht die heißeste nacht des
jahres zumindest im westen deutschlands
und das liegt daran dass da dichte
wolken liegen und an der nordsee gibt es
auch mal gewitter das führt dazu dass in
den innenstädten von köln düsseldorf
oder auch im ruhrgebiet die werte kaum
unter 25 grad
es bleibt also eine tropische nacht
angenehmer sind die nachttemperaturen in
bayern bei 16 bis 14 grad
morgen erwarten uns im nordwesten
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 25 und 29
grad zwischen rügen und dem spreewald
wird es heiss mit 30 bis 36 grad im
nordwesten kommen diese wolken weiter
nach osten voran es gibt zum teil
kräftige regenfälle und schon am
vormittag die ersten gewitter die weiten
sich dann am nachmittag aus dann kann es
auch mal über der lübecker bucht
gewittern
dafür aber lassen die regenfälle ganz im
westen nach und südlich der
mecklenburger seenplatte über das
erzgebirge bis nach süddeutschland
scheint die sonne strahlend nachmittags
allerdings kommen in rheinland pfalz im
saarland und in hessen dichtere wolken
am niederrhein und westlich des rheins
liegen die höchsttemperaturen morgen bei
26 bis 29 grad sonst wird es bei 30 bis
37 grad da freuen wir uns über die
abkühlung mit der kaltfront am samstag
am montag liegen die werte nur noch bei
18 bis 23 grad schönen abend noch